Olha só, pessoal, hoje eu vou responder
uma pergunta que chegou lá do
consultório e que muita gente tem
dúvida. Doutor, posso tomar café
seguindo uma dieta anti-inflamatória? E
tem alguma marca específica que eu
indico? Essa é daquelas perguntas que a
gente adora responder, né? Porque
envolve prazer e saúde ao mesmo tempo.
Sabe o que que é interessante? A gente
vive numa época em que tudo parece ser
inflamatório, tudo parece ser mal. Mas
eu vou te dizer uma coisa que vai te
deixar feliz se você é do time do
cafezinho. O café não só pode, como deve
fazer parte de uma dieta
anti-inflamatória bem estruturada. E
olha que legal, a ciência está do nosso
lado nessa. Deixa eu explicar o que que
acontece quando você toma aquele
cafezinho. O café é naturalmente rico em
compostos bioativos. Sabe aqueles nomes
complicados que a gente aprende na
faculdade? Então são os polifenóis,
especialmente o ácido clorogênico, o
ácido cafeico e o caeol. Esses caras são
verdadeiros soldados antiinflamatórios
no nosso organismo. É como se você
estivesse mandando um exército bem para
combater a inflamação. Diversos estudos
recentes, inclusive alguns de 2025,
mostram que o consumo regular de café
está associado à redução significativa
de marcadores inflamatórios no sangue.
Sabe aquela proteína ser reativa que a
gente pede? regularmente. Pois é, quem
toma café tende a ter níveis mais baixos
e não para por aí. Tem evidência de que
o café pode ajudar a prevenir diabetes
tipo 2, doenças cardiovasculares e até
doenças neurodegenerativas. Tudo isso
graças ao poder antiinflamatório e
antioxidante desses compostos. Agora,
tem um detalhe que descobrimos
recentemente e que me deixou surpreso.
Lembra que antigamente a gente dizia
para tomar café puro sem leite? Pois
bem, estudos novos mostram que quando
você adiciona leite ao café, pode haver
uma potencialização do efeito
anti-inflamatório. Os polifenóis do café
se ligam às proteínas do leite e essa
combinação pode dobrar a eficácia na
modulação inflamatória. Claro, estamos
falando de um leite caseina A2 e de boa
qualidade e de preferência orgânico.
Nada daquele leite de caixinha cheio de
conservantes, OK? Mas olha, nem todo
mundo responde igual ao café. A genética
conta muito aqui. Tem gente que
metaboliza a cafina rapidinho, outros
demoram mais. Uma minoria pode até
perceber um aumento de inflamação,
especialmente se tiver alguma
intolerância específica. Por isso, é
importante observar como é que seu corpo
reage. Agora vamos ao que interessa para
muita gente. Quais marcas eu recomendo
aqui no Brasil? Eu vou te dar uma lista
bacana, porque qualidade faz toda a
diferença quando estamos falando de
benefícios para a saúde. Primeiro vamos
falar dos cafés orgânicos, que são a
minha primeira escolha sempre. O café
Orfeu, produzido lá em Minas Gerais a
1200 m de altitude, é sensacional. Tem
certificação orgânica 100% arábica. E
olha que interessante, eles ganharam
vários prêmios internacionais. O sabor
tem notas de chocolate caramelo e é um
café que não agride.
Outra marca que eu gosto muito é a
Native. Essa empresa é referência em
produtos orgânicos no Brasil e o café
deles não fica atrás. Eles têm desde
torra clara até extra forte. Então você
escolhe conforme o seu paladar. E o
legal é que são super rigorosos com a
questão dos agrotóxicos, zero química
prejudicial. O café dultra não é da
minha família, também merece destaque
especial. Olha só que bacana, mais de
100 prêmios nacionais, internacionais em
qualidade e sustentabilidade. Eles têm
uma linha orgânica que é uma delícia e
dá para sentir a diferença na xícara. É
produzir nas montanhas de Minas em
pequenas lavouras, sem agrotóxicos nem
fertilizantes químicos. Para quem
procura algo mais acessível, mas ainda
assim de qualidade, tem o Santa Clara
Orgânico. É fácil de encontrar em
supermercados e mantém um padrão bem
legal. Claro que não é um café especial
como os outros que eu mencionei, mas
para o dia a dia que abrungalho danado.
Se você não encontrar os orgânicos,
outras marcas de boa qualidade são a
Melita Linha Gourmet, o Três Corações
Gourmet da região da Mogiana Paulista e
o Pilão Cafeteria. Não são orgânicos,
mas são cafés 100% arábica de regiões
premiadas com controles e qualidade
decente. Agora eu vou te dar umas dicas
de ouro para potencializar ainda mais o
efeito antiinflamatório do cafezinho.
Primeira coisa, evite, não tome com
açúcar refinado. Eu sei, eu sei que tem
gente que não consegue tomar sem açúcar,
mas o açúcar vai brigar com o efeito bom
do café. O açúcar é pró-inflamatório,
então você estaria anulando boa parte
dos benefícios. Se precisar doçar, use
um pouquinho de stévia puro. Segunda
dica, experimente adicionar especiarias
antiflamatórias ao seu café. Uma
pitadinha de canela doilão ou de cúrcuma
pode transformar o seu café numa
verdadeira poção antiinflamatória.
Tem gente que torce o nariz, mas fica
uma delícia, acredite. Terceira, prefira
cafés de torra média ou clara. A torra
muito escura destrói parte dos
polifenóis benéficos. Aquele café pretão
forte demais, além de ser mais ácido pro
estômago, tem menos compostos
antiinflamatórios. E sobre a quantidade,
o consenso científico atual fala em três
a quatro xícaras por dia para adultos
saudáveis, o que dá uns 400 mg de cafína
por dia. Mas atenção, se você tem
pressão alta, o ideal é limitar a duas
xícaras grávidas também deve moderar no
máximo 200 mg de cafeína por dia. Tem um
detalhe importante que muita gente não
sabe. O método de preparo influencia nos
benefícios. O café coado no filtro de
papel retém parte dos diterpenos que em
excesso podem aumentar o colesterol. Já
o expresso e a prensa francesa deixam
passar mais desses compostos. Para
efeito antiinflamatório, todos são bons,
mas se você tem problemas aí de lipídios
altos, prefira o cuado. Ah, e uma
curiosidade que eu descobri
recentemente, o Brasil é o segundo maior
consumidor de café do mundo, perdendo
apenas pros Estados Unidos em volume
total. Mas em consumo por cabeça per
capta, a gente ganha, são mais de 6 kg
por ano por pessoa. E sabe o que que
significa? que temos acesso a cafés de
altíssima qualidade, produzidos aqui
mesmo, apesar que a maioria vai paraa
exportação. Para finalizar, quero deixar
bem claro, o café quando de boa
qualidade consumido com moderação, é um
aliado poderoso numa dieta defamatória,
mas lembre-se, ela faz parte de um
conjunto. Não adianta tomar três xícaras
de café orgânico por dia e comer fast
food no almoço, né? A dieta
anti-inflamatória é um estilo de vida
que inclui alimentos integrais, vegetais
coloridos, gorduras boas, proteínas de
qualidade e sim aquele cafezinho
gostoso. Então, na próxima vez que
alguém falar que café faz mal, você já
sabe o que responder. Só vai fazer mal
para algumas pessoas e em grandes
quantidades. Escolha uma marca de
qualidade, de preferência orgânica.
Prepare com carinho e aproveite não só o
sabor e o aroma, mas também todos os
benefícios antiinflamatórios que essa
bebida milenar nos oferece.
Saúde.
Compartilhe os vídeos, faça bem. A vida
de alguém pode mudar também. No canal do
Além do Tr se envolva. Ah.